ladies and gentlemen this is a kind of
unusual pretty big celebrity recently
reached out to me and asked if he could
make his stand-up comedy debut on this
show I mean we've had a lot of people
get their start doing stand-up here hmm
but this call just blew me away and I
said wow I can't believe this guy's
calling me why not so please welcome
trying his hand at stand-up comedy for
the very first time Santa Claus
[Music]
okay let's do this
I'm about to drop some truth bombs down
your chimneys people let's talk about
wrapping paper oh yeah I'm going there
hey I have an idea let's kill a bunch of
trees also your stupid kids won't know
that you got them some crappy plastic
toys that reinforce patriarchal gender
norms and we'll probably built my child
labor and a country where it's illegal
for women to drive that's wrapping paper
in a nutshell killing trees for the
oligarchy also some garbage man can feel
stronger hey check it out I'm really
strong now I can lift this whole bag
filled a crumpled up wrapping paper with
one hand
now I can use my other free hand to
drink a beer I love America what else
[Applause]
what else
oh yeah it's my setlist and I'm checking
it twice batteries not included
I'll say it again batteries not included
of course they're not included why
should you expect the thing you bought
to be able to do the thing you bought it
for without having to buy more things to
put inside the thing you already bought
the man just wants you to buy more
things for your things man oh yeah you
have the right to remain spending
[Laughter]
[Applause]
here's something you guys know that I'm
just your parents right I'm just your
parents okay I just gave you a present
that doesn't need any wrapping it was
called the truth and guess what
the truth doesn't need batteries you've
been great up in santa claus everybody
that really yeah it's called the truth
tone and you should try it sometime
all right Santa will be appearing for
the next three nights in the backroom of
the Los Angeles downtown Marxist and
lesbian bookstore so you can see it
there Santa Claus everybody
you